それでこの なんで認識することだけ
たった唯一の働きである
唯一の働きであって そんなに心が変わるんですかと
もわかっていると思います
喫茶店でいて喫茶店を認識する
こちらにてこの部屋を認識する
だから認識することだけだから
でもそれだけでは物事済まないんですね
ここで認識する私と喫茶店で認識する
喫茶店を認識する私が違うんです
なんでそんなたくさん心があるんですか？数えられないほど心があるんですかというと
それは心処の問題で そこで私はわかりやすい例えを使っているんです
だいたい教える場合は
世の中で水といえばたった一つしかないんです
たった一つの水しか世の中でないんです
それはあくまでも論理上
論理的に考えると 水っていうのは水素二つに
あの 何でしたっけ オキシジェン
酸素ですね 酸素個 もういろんな形でつなげているだけで
そこでまあイオンのいろいろ変化によって
また水の色違うところあるかもしれません
やっぱりまあ水だったらそんなもんなんですね
いわゆるまあ九十九パー九十九点九九パーセントの純粋な水ではなくて
百パーセントの純粋な水といえばたった一種類しかないんです
でもその水が実際しますかというと
全然実際しないんですね H2O
だけの水は イオン一個二個でももう欠けてるかなんとかとか
全然実際しない それで我々にはありとあらゆる水があるんですね
例えば海の水がありまして
日本のどんないろんなところに水があるんだけど
日本の水はすごい綺麗ですよと我々は俗的に言うんだけど
でも綺麗な水で入れも同じものでしょうに
そうじゃないんですね
いろんなところで水をサンプル取ってみると
それ違うんですね そこで世の中で飲み物もまたたくさんあるんですね
数えられない じゃあどう説明しますか？その場合は
その場合は水があって
水の中に他のものは溶けているんですね
その溶けているものをもって我々は水を認識する
例えば紅茶ですよ お茶ですよと言ったところで
水があって その水の中に何か溶けているんですね
それで我々は水をそんなに気にしない
気にするのは溶けているものなんですね
だからお茶と言うんです
あれはお茶をより倍水を入れて
それにちょっとコーヒー入れちゃう
そうすると我々はこっち二倍水あるのに
あ これはコーヒーだとすぐ決めてしまっちゃう
これはオレンジジュースだと
これはコーラだと これは海水だと
これは井戸の水だと これは水道の水だと
と決めちゃうんですね
だからお茶ですよという場合は
我々は水を考えていない
水の中に溶けている成分を考えているんです
スープですよと言って飲むのは水ですけど
その中にほんのちょっと溶けているものを考えてスープですよと思っちゃう
だいたい 人間の体って我々食べるものとかほとんど水の方が多いでしょうに
味噌汁例えば味噌汁の中で九十パーセント以上あるのは水なんですけど
でも味噌汁だと言っちゃうんでしょうね
そこですね この問題は
だからこの知識の世界では
この そういう感情だけで言ってしまっちゃったんだから
すごい大きな世界になってるんです
で 仏教はやっぱりそういうふうな認識で心に入るもの
心の中に生まれるもの
考えて心処と言うんです
そこでなんで心処という字が当てたんですかというと
水が場所であって その水の中にお茶たる成分が溶けているんですね
だからお茶たる成分の住処なんですね
水が そこで紅茶にしたっても水があって
この紅茶たる成分の住処なんですね
水は それで我々の心があって
心にいろんな感情というものは入っちゃう
入って心が住処にしているんです
ですから まあ考えたことはぴったし考えて漢字を当ててますけど
心処 わからないだけは問題なんですね
だからすぐちゃんと定義を聞いてみると
なるほど やっぱりこういう感情には心臓と心臓としか言う方法がないので
心はところを通しているんだ
場所を通し使っているんだっていうことなんですね
心を場所を通して住処として使っているものを心臓という
意味は通ってるんだけど
現代的にはなかなかパーリ語のことも同じなんですね
チェータシカというのはチッタの中にあるという意味なんです
チッタの中に住んでいるものだからチェータシカというんです
チェータシカということは
そういうふうに出来上がっているんです
そこで我々に怒りやら欲やら嫉妬
もうつまらないと いろんな感情があるでしょうね
そういうのは心の中にあるものなんですね
あの これからもう一つ
この体の痛みあるでしょ？体が痛い
足が痛いと あれも体にあるんじゃないんです
心にあるんです 体が痛くも何でもないんです
体があって心が体を認識する
その時は気持ちいいと認識したり
気持ち悪いと認識したり
痛いと認識したりするんです
だいたい普通の人はやっぱり足が痛いんだからと
私はもうちょっともうちょっと事故があって
もう腰がもう今痛いんだと
それは事実で見ようとしているんですね
でもそうじゃないんです
そこはもうだいたいこの修行の世界のこと言いますけど
みんな我が儘ですから
もういい加減で言うことやりませんだけどね
いろいろ文句言うでしょ
自分が座れないんだとかね
もう腰が痛くてああですこうですとかね
それでも言う通りにやりなさいと
もし強引にやらせてみると
あの痛みも何の関係もなくなっちゃうんです
私は歩けないんだ 歩けないんだとかね
まあたまに腹が立った方がいいなと私も思いますけど
こういちいち文句言うと
もう今更なんですかと
もう先もないのにと で
自分の立場としては怒りませんだが
怒るわけにはいきませんだから
で そんなわがままなくてね
例えば私は歩けないんだとか何とか言ってる人でも
80歳の90歳のおじいちゃんばあさんでも
もうちゃんと近隣瞑想してみてください
自分の固定観念がすぐ消えるはずなんです
この心を理解していくと
やっぱりこの痛みやらだるいやらもう硬いやら
そういうものは心が作る感情なんです
本当に我々は年取るか弱くなるかってのは分かったもんじゃないんです
心なんです 全部決まってるのは
じゃあ自分が何歳ですかね
心に聞いてみてください
自分の年を この何？あれですか
この出産なんとか登録ありますね
それから計算して私はこれぐらいこれぐらいだとかね
そういうふうに言われて教えられて心にいるんだから
私たちはもう年取って体が弱くなって病気になって
ああだこうだということになってるんです
じゃあ正直に自分の心に聞けば
自分は何歳かと言えば
全然答えが出てこないんです
心自体にはそんな何歳かっていうことは全くないんです
ですから この自分が例えば 60歳やと心で認識すれば
その心が 60歳にふさわしい感情を受けなくちゃいけないんだと思うんですね
それで 60歳にふさわしい感情って何でしょうかと
わからないでしょ？人に聞くんです
ずっと生きるとはそういうことだから
まあそうすると まあまあ
それだったらここら辺痛くて
膝が硬くてとかね 血圧が高くてとかね
糖尿病になりかけてとかね
いろいろなことを教えてくれる
そうすると心はそういう現象を全部作ってくる
それでまあ年取って亡くなっちゃうんですね
そんなものなければどうなるかってわかったもんじゃないんです
痛いと思えば痛いで 痛くないと思えば痛くないんですね
この暗示するかける場合はものすごいおかしいことをするでしょうに
誰も先生 なんでそうなるかわからないでしょ？別に何のこともないんです
心に言っちゃえばそれだけのことなんです
あなたの手はすごい硬くて
もうどうしても下がれませんよと
いくら押してもこれは下がります
ちょっとそれだけのこと
下がれません 人に暗示かけて
あんたはもう例えばケーキ見るともう気持ち悪くて苦くて苦くて
もうもう吐きそうになりますよと暗示かけてみてください
ケーキ見るとそうなるんです
それは本当は嘘の世界じゃなくて
それが真実の世界なんです
ケーキは美味しい 甘い
美味しい そんなあるはずがないんです
心で決まってるんだからそうなっちゃいます
ですからこの この痛み
その楽しみを怠いとか弱いとか強いとか
そういうのは一つも体の事実ではないんです
それは心の感情の問題
だからそこら辺 実験しなきゃわからないでしょうし
ですから実験しなくちゃいけないんです
サティの実践もいくらかもう知識を得たければ
もうそういうひらめきが堂々といろんなもの出てくるんです
だからこの修行 人の個人次第ですけど
このヴィパッサナー瞑想を進んでみると
もういくらでも知恵も知識ももう湧いてくるんです
本当の姿が見えてくるんだから
そこら辺でいろんなことを理解しようとするならば理解できる
お釈迦様はヴィパッサナー瞑想でもう自分が一切小さなりましたというのはそういうことだから
今の人々はそこまでいけませんだけど
もう でもできないわけでもないんです
じゃあとにかくこの心があって
心が物事を認識すると
いろいろ感情を作る その作る感情が 52種類があって
で 心の中に感情があって
体にあるわけじゃないんです
そこで心象って何でしょうかと定義する場合は
心とこういう定義なんですね
心と一緒に生まれてます
Ekupāda Ekupāda
rodati ekalambana vattata というふうにありますけど
日本語でどう書いてるんですかね
動機ですね 動機という感じなんですけど
動機心が現れると一緒に生まれる eka
uppāda この eka というのは one という意味で [音楽]ウッパードっていうのは生まれるという意味なんですね
それつなげてエクッパードと言うんです
パーリ語の言葉 こういう風に作るんです
エカっていうのはワン一つという意味で
それまたもう一つ一緒という意味もあるんですね
で ウッパードっていうのは生まれるということで
だから一緒に生まれるという意味なんですね
はい であの水と水の中に溶けているものと同じことで
まあ一緒ですからね 水が生まれると同時にもう水の中に溶けているものはそこにあるんです
たとえ雨の一滴にしても
もう空気の中でやっぱりいろいろほこりやいろんなものがあって
そこで水になっちゃいますからね
生まれるともう中にいろんなものが入ってるんです
ですから この 100%の純粋な水っていうのは瞬間でもないんです
いません ありません すごい気をつけて
ものすごいとことん厳密な研究なんて言いますか
実験機械とかいろいろ装備があって
その中で作られますけど
それはすごい強引なやり方で
そうでないとない ですから
この心が生まれると一緒にもう感情も生まれているんです
それで心が消えると消えちゃうんですね
エカニロード この皆様のテキストでは
この何ページでしたっけ
47 ページの で  第2章なんですけど
1 1 1番目なんですね
E
k uppada nirodhacha ek alambana vatthuka cheto yutta dhipanya
sa dhamma chetasika
mata  47番目の 1行 1番目 47 ページの 1
で それを定義で 大体学生さんたちがそういうのはすぐそのまま暗記しちゃうんですね
それでもうすぐ大変難しい勉強はすぐもう頭の中に入り込んじゃうんです
ですから パーリ語はあれですが
問題ですけどね まあ覚えてしまえばEk uppada nirodhacha ek alambana vatthuk
a cheto yutta dhipanyasa
dhamma chetasika mataそれだけ
で Ek nirodha一緒になくなると
その場合は日本語の言葉は同滅です
同滅かな で ニローダっていうのは消えていく
なくなることなんですね
だから感情が心と一緒に生まれて
その心が消えると もうなくなっちゃうんです
我々 経験上知っているでしょうね
例えば すごくうるさい音が入ると
もううるさいという感情があって
音が消えても はぁうるさいとあのイライラ感情でいるんですかね
それ すぐ消えちゃうんです
この教室の中にいるとつまらなくてつまらなくて
外を出ちゃったらもうすぐそれ消えちゃいますから
外を出てもつまらないとか
家に戻ってもあーつまらないというふうな
そういうことはないんです
その違う心が生まれると
あの前の感情はもうもう終わってるんですね
エクッパ―で拾ってあげて
次にエーカーランバナ
特色といえばね これとこれとこれですね
エーカーランバナっていうのは 3つ三番目
このアーランバナという言葉
これやっぱりよく覚えて理解して勉強しておいてください
これものすごくいつでも使わなくちゃいけない言葉なんです
アーランバナ これこのテキストはこの所縁と訳しているんですね
所縁だけでよろしいですね
ここは何かあるんですけど
最初 この じゃあまずこの漢字を忘れて意味を聞いてください
アーランバナ 心がこの何かを認識するでしょう
その何かがなければ心が生まれるはずがないんです
いわゆる生命が 生命がいるということは
別に大胆なことではなくて
何かを認識する その機能に生命と呼ぶんです
そこで この何かが認識しない場合は
この何かを認識するものがなくなっちゃったら
別にそこに生命いるということではなくなるんですね
そこでこのいわゆる引っ掛けというか
この そういうもの 例えばこういうことで
で ここにいて 私が目を開けるとこの部屋を見えちゃうんですね
だから部屋が部屋を私が認識する
それでここに私という生命はいることになってしまっちゃうんですね
だからどっちから言ったってもいいんだけど
部屋がいて こちらに認識機能を起こしちゃったと
それで生命という現象が生まれたんだと
あるいはこちらで認識機能があって
そこは別にもう働かない
でもたまたま部屋に出会って認識機能が生まれて
そこで生命は誕生しましたと
どっちの方向で言ったっても同じことなんです
そこら辺はものすごい難しい
すごい深い深い哲学になりますけどね
あまり詳しい説明はできませんだけど
ですから簡単に考えてください
ここに部屋がありますと仮定すると
あったとしても別に関係ないんだけど
そこで部屋があるんだという認識が生まれちゃったと
そうすると その瞬間でそこに生命の誕生なんですね
環境を認識しちゃったんだから
そんな方向で考えると
まず世界があって そこに生命が誕生するということになっちゃうんですね
あるいは認識する機能があるんだと
認識する機能だけあったっても機能しませんだから
認識するものがなければ
そこで部屋を認識しちゃったと
そうすると生命というものは誕生だと
それはこの唯識的な思考方法なんですね
認識機能があって その認識機能が物事を認識すると
それは生命の誕生であると
それで世一切有部と苦沙論的な立場っていうのはやっぱり逆で
客観的ないろんなものがあって
それを認識してしまっちゃうんだから
そこで生命の誕生だと
そこで苦沙論と唯識派っていうのはすごい正反対で
お互いに喧嘩してるんだけど
別にもうただどちらの方向で物を見ているかということだけで
そんなに差があるわけじゃないんです
喧嘩しなきゃ気が済まないんだから
まあそういうタイプ 喧嘩でてるだけ
どちらが正しいとはちょっと言えないんですね
まあそれは仏教の世界
仏教的な知ってる方々は理解できるだろうと思いますけど
我々はごく俗的に一般的に考えましょう
そこで私が部屋を見る
だからあるいは美しい花を見る
花を見てああ綺麗だとかいろんな感情が生まれる
そこでこの花に寄りかかって綺麗だという感情が生まれるんじゃないんですか
花をよりどころにして
花に依存して この綺麗な感情が生まれる
綺麗という感情が生まれる
で 音があると その音をよりどころにして
自分の心の中に綺麗美しいさ
気持ちいいという感情が生まれたら
私たちはその音に音楽だとまた名付けたりはする
ですから この心の中に感情が生まれるために
何かに引っかからなきゃダメなんです
何かに引っかかって心の中で新しい波が生まれる
だから今の皆様の心の流れでも違う引っ掛け出しちゃったら違う心が生まれる
それはコントロールできない
私はもしテープレコーダーでも持ってきて
カセットデッキで持ってきて音を出しちゃえば
じゃあその通りに心の中で感情が生まれ始めちゃうんです
これはもうコントロールすることもどうすることもできない
ですから この引っ掛けがあると
そこに認識が生まれる
同時に感情が生まれる
そこで心が 例えばラジオから出る音を認識する
そうすると その心に感情が生まれる
その感情も音だから生まれるでしょう
例えばラジオから音楽が流れている場合は
聴いている人は楽しくなる
ですから 楽しいという感情が生まれたのは音の原因で
音のせいなんですね そこで音があるんだ
だから私はいるんだという存在実感も
それも認識ですね それも音から生まれたんですね
ですから心が生まれて思惟が生まれる
その場合は同じものに寄りかかっている
音に寄りかかっている
音を聴くと 音を聴いているという感情も
それに音に対する音を聴いているという認識も
音に対する感情も 音から生まれてくるというか
音に寄りかかって生まれる
ですから所縁と言うんですね
所縁というのは対照ということで
認識を引き起こす 原因なんですね
ですから 音やら目に見えるものやら
体に触れるものやら 全部認識引き起こす原因
その認識引き起こす原因は所縁というんです
所縁でなくても違う言葉でもいいし
私はこの所縁という漢字の組み合わせはあまり個人的にあまり好きじゃないんだから
対象という で この縁はこの因縁の縁ですから
やっぱりよく考えて作ってはいるんです
ですから この我 私の中では音楽を聴いて
いろんな感情が生まれる場合は
感情の原因も音である
認識の原因も音であります
ですから この思惟が思惟の所縁
思惟の対象も栄華乱でない
同じ対象です あ もうお忘れになったかもしれません
心と一緒に生まれる 心と一緒に消える
心と一緒の対象を取っている
という意味なんです いわゆる心と離れませんね
どうしても  4番目は栄華
栄華とて多分間違いないです
だけ で 切って 栄華と 栄華とっていうのは
あの動機度は入ってない
このワットっていうはこの認識起こる場所を認識起こる場所を考えてワットと呼ぶんです
で よく聞くでしょ 心はどこにありますかと
じゃあ魂はどこにあるんですかね
人間の よくこの宗教哲学の世界でよく聞く質問なんです
ヒンドゥー インド宗教では
インド教ではね やっぱり魂はどこにありますかということは考えて
ちゃんと答えまで出してるんです
魂の大きさはこれぐらいとかね
まあ仏教では魂という概念はないし
霊魂という概念もないし
そんなものはもうないという立場で喋ってますけど
心があると言ってるんだから
同じものではない 同じものでもないし
心はえらい変化しますからね
それで心はどこにありますかと
心っていうのは認識する機能だから
やっぱり場所 考えたっても構いませんし
考えなくても構いません
で 場所 心の場所っていうのは
別に定めてない なぜかというと
認識する機能だから定めることはできない
例えば 私は目を閉じて指先で人差し指で何かを触ってみる
目を閉じている こうやって触ると私は何をしているんですか？ちゃんと指先で何かを認識しているんですね
そうすると指先にこの触れる感じが生まれる
そこに心が生まれるんです
指先に 目を閉じて指一本の指で何かちょっと触れてみると
あそこで何かあるんだという微かな認識が生まれるでしょう
ということは そこに心が生まれるということ
そこは場所なんです 心が生まれる場所なんです
別に じゃあ指先だけですかね
我々は物事を知っているのは
じゃあ頭でもちょっと痒くなっちゃったらちゃんとそれ知ってるでしょうに
そこでそこに心が生まれる
それだけですかね 例えばお腹が痛くなったらどうなるんですか？そこで痛いと
お腹が痛いと感じるでしょう
そこでそこに心が生まれている
とにかく認識することを心ですから
ですから体中心が生まれるんです
で いろんなものを 自分の体から離れているようなものを見える場合は
何を通して見ているんで
目を通して見ているんですね
そこで目のどこかはっきりはちょっとはっきりはわかりませんだけどね
私たちは でも 目の中で何かがあって
そこら辺でそれを認識しちゃう
で 耳があって音を認識する
そういうふうに認識する場所いっぱいあります
体中 認識する場所は心が生まれる場所
ということは 心には定まった場所がありえないということなんです
ですから 仏教の人に心はどこにありますかというと
まあこうするしかどうかなとか言うしか答えがないんです
頭かいてもうどうでしょうかと言って
何かごまかすしか方法ないんです
なぜならば 質問する人にとってはこの霊魂みたいに
この実体がずっと変化しない何かが
この体の中に尊いものがあるんではないかという概念で
それで聞いてるんだから
このウパニシャッド哲学では
この心 魂というのはアートマンというのはアングスティマートラプリタスといって
この親指ぐらいのものだと
それ形は人の形をとっているんだと
それはその体の中にあるんだと
でも今 細胞ごとの人間の体を解体しますけど
DNA まで分解していろいろ見るんだけど
ただの化学 化学ね でしょ
あれは このアミノ酸ですね
あれ アミノ酸分解したらただのアミノ酸だから
ただの物質まで行っちゃったんだけど
そんなものは見つからないんですね
その物質さえまた分解すると原子が出てきて
その原子がいろいろ出てくるんだけど
そこ 働いている霊魂でも魂でも何の見つからないし
それで仏教から見る何かこういう霊魂でも精神でも魂でも何かあるというならば
各一つ一つの原子の中にもなければいけませんし
ですから 体中あるんですね
心が そこで心っていうのは心というものがありません
ただの働き それがこのそれでも我々に心が生まれないところはあるんです
体の中にも 例えば髪の毛
髪の毛は髪の毛の中に心が生まれません
髪の毛を触ってもわからない
この髪の毛をつなげている皮膚でわかるのであって
ですから皮膚でわからない場合は
人の髪の毛を切ったっても
本人は全然気がつかない
このスネですか スネのもう伸びちゃったら
そこには神経もないし
だから切っても痛みもないし
認識はしない でもスネ毛ってよく我々知ってますけど
その場合はこの皮膚のところで知ってるんですね
この振動 振動を認識しているんです
体の中でどうでしょうかね
まあ脳細胞にはないみたいですね
認識機能は 一番おかしい話ですけど
まあどうかわかりませんだけど
とにかくまあ別にまあ仏教にはそんなことどうでもいいことで
もう脳細胞は自分の自分がいるんだっていうことを知ってるならば
それで結構ですから それで心が生まれちゃいますからね
脳細胞というのはバカバカらしくて
例えば一部をいじるととんでもないことを認識するんですね
いじめているんだと認識しないんです
脳のいろんな働き部分があります
例えばあの視覚というんですか
あの見える部分をちょっといれちゃうと
いろんなものが見えてしまっちゃうんですね
別にあるものでもないんです
他のところへ行っちゃうと
また過去のことを思い出したり
あるいは喋り出したりとか
まあ余計なことをしてしまっちゃうんですけど
だからあれで本当に認識してるんでしょうかと
わからない なんで自分のことを認識できないんですかね
だからおかしいんです
そのおかしい脳細胞は我々すごい大事に考えちゃいますけどね
まあとにかく認識する場所
ワットなんですね 基元それでこの心臓も心も一緒のところで生まれる
例えば私は目を閉じて何か指先で触ろうと思ったところで
ロウソクの炎を触ってみたんだと
そうすると火傷するでしょうね
そうすると痛いでしょうし
そこで痛いという感情も指先に生まれる
そこで私は前言ったことと何か矛盾するんじゃないかなと思いますけど
体には痛みは別にはないんだと
で ないんだけど 我々なんで体に痛みがあるんだと思うのは
この指先の中に指先の指先に心が生まれるでしょ
それで火傷した場合は
そこで心が痛いという感じを作るんですね
その指先の指先に生まれるんですね
そこで我々指先が痛い
痛いというんです 指先が痛いんじゃなくて
その場でも心に痛みの感情が生まれるということで
もし指先の指に認識できなくなったと
そうすると人が指を持って火で燃やしちゃっても知らないんだから
痛くも何にもないんですね
脂のってるんだからチリチリとよく見える可能性もあります
その時は痛いということはないし
ですからこの これはまあ認識が生まれるかないかということだけのことで
体 我々はまあ執着するとかしない
じゃあえーと まあその 4つの特色は心祖の特色
心と一緒に生まれる 一緒に亡くなる
心と一緒の同じものに引かれて認識する
それから心と同じ場所に生まれるという 4つなんですね
教科書ではワットカーってついてるんですけど
ワットゥか 教科書にはワットゥじゃなくてワットゥカーだと
まあそれはそれで これはこれ
で そこは説明できない
まあこの場合はワットと書いても間違いはないんですが
一応覚える場合 エカワットっていうのは元の言葉なんですね
芸文でええかええかええかと全部出てこないでしょ
それはもう芸文だから
まあそういう文法的にいろんな組み合わせがありますのでね
それは文法の世界ですから
まあここでは扱うわけにはいきません
それで心臓終わりますと心祖
じゃあ心祖は 52種類ありますということも